voilà si vous voulez faire acte de
générosité vente aux enchères demain à
20 heures au cirque d'hiver cérémonie
précisé a précisément par carla bruni
qui est avec nous ce soir bonsoir
pourquoi avez vous accepté de présider
cette manifestation et quelle est votre
implication personnelle dans la lutte
contre le sida
eh bien j'ai accepté de présider cette
association par soutient aussi parce que
notre non plus n'est devenu très célèbre
dernièrement je parle des top models en
général et c'est intéressant de pouvoir
utiliser notre nom dans quelque chose
d'autre que la publicité personnelle ou
les défilés ou le monde de la mort de
toujours la même chose il ya des causes
très importante solidarité sida est très
très proche des jeunes là une
communication très importante de
prévention aussi avec les jeunes et je
crois que dans ce milieu là nous pouvons
faire beaucoup de choses nous les
mannequins parce que nous touchons à ces
les jeunes donc nous pouvons nous porter
un peu parole de la prévention et de
l'aide aux malades aussi sauf erreur de
ma part vous aviez déjà vous est-il gens
impliqués dans la lutte contre le cancer
oui c'est à dire que le monde de la mode
a toujours été très organisée pour ce
genre de choses nous avons fait beaucoup
de
de soirée de défilé il ya des filets du
rayon vert mais quelque chose d ombre de
solidarité sida
le monde de la mode est engagée très
touché par ce terrible fléau aussi et
donc je crois que tout le monde
d'ailleurs tous les grands couturiers où
on sait c'est le nombre et toutes les
mannequins ainsi donc nous sommes
facilement dans ce genre d'organisation
et c'est tant mieux alors il ya une
centaine d'ong on l'a dit entre autres
celle de la vespière d'amou kekele dans
toutes ces personnalités celle que vous
aviez ol plus haut la lie à nelson
mandela aussi il y a dans tous les
milieux il y a les personnalités les
plus exceptionnelles et les plus
extraordinaires ça va de johnny hallyday
à anosy mandela à karl lagerfeld c'est
tout à fait éclectique et c'est je sais
pas j'aimerais acheter au moins dix
jours
vous avez joué les intermédiaires pour
convaincre le genre depardieu un petit
peu c'était pas très difficile jardin
dit aussi beaucoup de générosité en ce
qui concerne ces genres de choses
vous êtes une de ces ombres alors
comment vous jugez le tableau du
meilleur génial qu'est ce que vous
pensez vous qu'ils avaient vécu dans une
famille très artiste de ce cette forme
d'art je pense que ce qui est le plus
touchant dans ces ombres c'est que la
personnalité de la personne ressort
vraiment on comprendre la personne
imposée devant la toile on comprend ce
n'est pas une photographie parce que il
ya du mouvement dans ces ombres et donc
on reconnaît les gens de par leur
mouvement même sans les connaître on les
reconnaît immédiatement
ce qui transparaît le plus c'est la
magie de l'ombre et mouvements des
personnes qui nous permet de les
reconnaître sans voir leurs traits merci
toute dernière question d'un mot quand
on dit que vous êtes carrossée par
botticelli ça vous fait sourire ça me
flatte beaucoup je sais pas si merci
beaucoup en tout cas à carla bruni
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir pour
parler de cette vente aux enchères dont
le demain au cirque d'hiver sont
difficiles sagna très très très nombreux
voilà bah je pense que rien pour votre
sourire peut-être beaucoup de gens
viendront et puis pour acheter des
toiles j'allais vous proposer une soirée
avec vous mais je me sens que ce n'est
pas dans la poche